if you're a fan of the GTA series then
chances are you've probably heard or
seen the name leslie benzies show up
every now and then after 15 years
president of Rockstar North Benzies has
left the studio Rockstar Games confirmed
his exit with kotaku earlier today
according to the site Benzies has been
on sabbatical for the past 17 months a
rockstar representative said we can
confirm that Leslie Benzies went on
sabbatical on September first 2014 and
has decided not to return to work for
the company we are very grateful for
Leslie's contributions to rock star over
the last 15 years as we work together to
make some amazing games Leslie helped us
build an incredible team that will
continue to create great experiences for
our fans Leslie will always be a friend
to the company and of course we are
going to miss him but we wish him the
absolute best for the future 19-year
Rockstar veteran Aaron Garbutt and Rob
Nelson will be taking over fans ease
management roles Ben Z's a Scotland
native has lived in Edinburgh for more
than a decade where Rockstar North has
developed every grand theft auto game
since grand theft auto 3 it's a shame to
see such a key figure and one of the
most famous franchises go but all things
must come to an end for more on grand
theft auto 5 you're already in the right
place